yeah yeah no karma is a [__] only if
you are that's right karma's a blessing
if you are that's beautiful that's a
great way of saying it
all right Billy and Valerie Billy and
Valerie where are you guys from Texas
Bernie well I I'm from Bernie Texas
that's where I grew up and graduated
he's from all over the place no I grew
up I've known her since she was six
years old six years old yeah I was six
he was small town small town it was your
uh what was your family's what were your
families like
should we start Catholics both of us yes
okay my dad was a truck driver and my
dad my mom was uh Avon uh
home interior Tupperware you know uh all
that social butterfly everybody in town
never loved her she was a majorette in
high school you know
she uh she got cancer when I was young
so I kind of put a damper on things my
brothers one of them lived with my
grandmother
my oldest brother did so he didn't live
at home my middle brother he got all the
[__] he had the trash detail due to the
dishes that was spoiled run you were
spoiled the middle one was spoiled no
well you I was spoiled right he was the
baby so he got everything he wanted I
was the oldest one
I was a latchkey kid I got nothing I I
would love to raise my sister I was
eight she was five
with a latchkey because my mom was a
nurse and we had to stay home alone
my dad was a truck driver too in fact
come years later find out my aunt was
married to his uncle so
you're not related by marriage yeah that
explains why my mom said stay away from
that biker bunch
they're in my whole family road
motorcycles so
but we never saw each other at any
family gatherings or anything like that
which was kind of weird but my mom had a
hand in keeping us apart
Bernie is a Texas Hill Country right
outside of San Antonio okay key to the
hills is what it's called I mean it's
right when you come into the hills and
all of it's open
a little Germantown yeah
predominantly German
what kind of kids were you guys in high
school you do a high school together
I was very much not in school after the
fifth grade I was homeschooled during
the fifth grade
and then I went back to public school
and I skipped the eighth grade all
together they put me right into High
School
and I didn't stay because my mom was
sick you know and my dad was still
working at that time so I spent a lot of
time at home
and I ended up quitting High School my
freshman year
I graduated with a two-week-old baby I
graduated a year late because my mom is
I emancipated myself at 16. I went to
the judge of the town with the paperwork
and I said sign this for me my mom won't
quit [__] with me at school I I was a
nerd I guess is what you would call it I
was in every activity I was the first
female trainer in the state of Texas
because Coach Brown went to bat for me
in Austin saying that this girl is going
to be it well I'm like a natural healer
I know all the medical stuff I helped my
mom passed her test to become a nurse
and all that [__] stuck so uh
where were we back in Bernie I graduated
like I said a year late with a
two-week-old there but my mom was there
my aunt was there
everybody was there and then I I put
myself straight into dental school and I
was in school and managing a bar at
night and this guy watched my baby her
first born yet
my my
wife at the time
was pregnant with my first daughter but
I was babysitting her daughter
yeah because I had to nurse her and the
only time I could nurse her is you know
I'll go to school all day my boobs get
full I come home and pick her up I nurse
her real quick go to the bar go work my
babysitter she would bring her back and
forth I would nurse her right there at
the bar and and work because I didn't
drink so it was easy for me to do and
that's what I did while I went through
school
even though I didn't graduate I did 10
months or eight months out of ten for
dental hygienist is that when you guys
became a couple after she left her
mom
we were closer friends then but uh we
weren't as like as a couple at all we
haven't been we were just best friends
we both have three marriages each
oh really yeah
so we just did you guys not married no
no no we just stayed in touch over the
years how long have you been traveling
together
four years now
2018 after Hurricane Harvey is when
well I got clean on the April 25th of
2018. Okay so
it was five years in April yeah um that
I've been cleaning the needle so I came
to him down in Corpus Christi he was
working there after the hurricane I told
him if he ever came back to Texas and
was single I was coming to him right
away
so I did I even hitchhiked out of
Houston while my husband was displaced
at another house my whole family got
separated after Harvey and uh I
hitchhiked out of Houston I sat outside
of Joel Osteen's Church
crying for a long time figuring out how
I was going to get to him because he
couldn't get me there I'm on I-35 I'm
going I don't care
from County to County I got cops see at
me from one County to the next because
they didn't want me in their County
you know just sitting on the side of the
road with my bags I thought you bought
her a ticket up with it
and I got a bus out of a town that
didn't have a name or a bus stop
it was kind of scary for me because I
was coming off the drugs and I thought
everybody was the enemy but many drugs
become a part of your lives mine are his
both
I was 11 when I got high on hash the
first time with my brothers I got two
older brothers or maybe so one six years
old and one's eight years older
and uh so I was introduced when I was 11
years old I started smoking hash and
weed Valerie
um I started smoking weed um I was like
11 babysitting in Houston and my baby
the one that lady I was babysitting for
she rolled me up some big fatties and
that's when I started smoking so drugs
have always been a part of your stories
sure man I mean I love I love the weed I
love that's what I started with was the
weed and then my cousin man she was like
you gotta try this and she was a one
year older than me I think I was 12 and
I got my first shot but it was horrible
because I didn't like the way it made me
feel it was speed I had no idea what was
going on I got sick I threw up I didn't
touch it again until I was like 16.
and my brother told me he I said I said
uh
damn it's like you soar with the Eagles
he said yeah you fly with the turkeys
just stay that way
well that made me want it even more
so by the time I was uh going to school
I did my first shot by myself in a
parking lot
because I had to stay awake I had things
to do I quit nursing the baby because of
it and everything I kept it to myself I
lied to everybody about it
so that's when I started doing it like
hardcore I never liked to be
and this is way back when it was like
real methamphet I mean you know not this
ice [__] that they got now but uh I
never really cared for it too much
because it make me a stupid you know
really and
it just wasn't for me I couldn't stay up
for days you know it'd be all right so
that's what I was using now I started
doing
crack when I was 14. correct it was
Freebase back in back in 84. so uh my
oldest brother introduced me to that
and I just I loved it how was the
quality of crack changed over the years
I haven't done it that long yeah I would
have to see you got to be real careful
where you get it who you get it from
because they put a lot of extra [__] in
it now you never know what yours again
have you a deed from fentanyl oh
absolutely not because fentanyl looks
like crap uh and that's what that's what
kills a lot of these things well we
haven't been here in three years all
right like I said again I'm real careful
where I get that [__] from and or are
you are you how long you been at Skid
Row
this is not my first time being down
here like this time how long have you
been here I've only been back for like a
week and a half okay yo be careful now
because
now there's this drug called all my
friends are telling me people are
slipping that [__] to other people just
confuses it some of my friends have died
I've seen dealers who who OD because
they don't realize that right that's the
part that they're using is not it's a
very terrible drug
I mean I'm gonna get my drink sure it's
a terrible thing you know and I would I
would never play with it personally I
would never play with it and I'm very
careful yeah but that's why there's a
lot of people that are no longer with us
because of that we have noticed uh
yeah it's uh where you guys staying now
here there I don't have a permanent
pleasure we just crashing wherever
so much more beautiful than Texas I was
gonna die in Texas I hate it there see
how kids are there so we go back here
quite often this evening
uh what's your relationship like with
your kids
I have a really actually a good
relationship with my kids uh I wasn't
really there for him when they were
growing up
after they were like 9 and 11 uh I
divorced their mom I left them
and uh I didn't see him again until they
were 17 18 so it was like seven eight
years Gap actually
and uh
I was in rehab when I got back in touch
with him and ever since then we've been
really cool you know I mean they know
everything about me I didn't lie to them
you know I told him why I left you know
and they accepted it and
I lied to mine the whole way they called
me they called me at least once a week
if my oldest son actually called me
probably twice a week
so are you guys a romantic couple or
just friends we became romantic
yeah my husband passed away and I was
having a hard time like being totally
for him because I was married you know
and uh my husband passed away and since
then we've gotten
I've only recently became able to trust
this guy because I didn't trust anybody
she had a lot of baggage from her past
relationships they weren't always
Pleasant more and she was just kind of
seeing me in the same like well he has
the same name as my second husband who
abused me and he was very
this is heavy he wouldn't even let me go
to my mom's house without when I came
back pulling down my pants to smell me
yeah he was very twisty he was a twisted
[__] he he [__] me up here and even
though my husband for 20 years like
tried to get me where I wasn't [__] up
when I wasn't around Allen anymore and
his name's Billy Joe his name was Billy
Jack
I did I looked at him in the same foul
[__] way it was hard the first couple
of years we were together you know
getting past that you know her damage
uh but luckily we've known each other
long enough where she can trust me now
nothing without luck
the luck is the result of hard work
that's because we're blessed but uh
truly blessed yeah we are we're
definitely
very close now
probably more more so than most girls
the only reason we had to come across
that desert again is because like I
didn't listen to God and I didn't listen
to him and I promised on my way to him
that I would I promised God I would
listen to him and I did anything but I
bucked the system the whole time because
I'm a tourist and I have a hard head and
a hard head makes for a soft ass
yeah sure we started out with nothing
then we we kind of got what we're happy
that's all right and then
we kind of went back down so we're
starting over again you know at least
I've done this before here so I know you
know the steps to take you know just
just be aware of that fentanyl for 10
years
because I mean it seems like there's
some kind of genocide going on here you
know knowing the person's selling it to
you will say no no it doesn't have any
fentanyl in it well I'm just saying you
know it's terrible a lot of people are
disappearing and we've seen so many
people gone
all right
I am very aware of the fentanyl [__] you
know I do not
take any chances at all we're not taking
anything that's open from anybody I
would never use anybody else's like pipe
and uh
nothing like that which I don't trust it
how do you guys support yourself
a salvage and recycle yeah at the
college yeah we make College in like
warehouses and clothing manufacturers
they throw out a lot of extra material
Trend and stuff I go and sell it to the
for each other's down here and for blow
so but you guys are honest yeah
absolutely 100 that's why you know what
when I came here my lessons you know I
mean I found 2 300 cash in the dumpster
why should I steal you know uh God
provides or whatever you can say because
people with excess excess excess access
to access that's what I tell him you
know uh this is the city of lost angels
and I'll tell you what people throw away
perfectly good items all the time I find
better stuff than I could still probably
you know honestly I do quite low you
know they give away clothes at the
emissions here yeah that you could sell
to a resale shop and like we get better
stuff at the college either brand new
501s I got an iPhone yesterday I've got
two pairs of them I mean I just haven't
had a shower that's why I'm in my
clothes right here because once we get a
shower I've got my good clothes in that
bag yeah we find a very nice job
do you guys get hotels for yourselves
three three four days yeah we'll get one
you know three or four days you know try
to put back some money then we just
weigh it out is it worth getting the
hotel room you know because right now
we're trying to get another vehicle so
we're like
we're trying to match it and get some
money together because we have Mission
we have God's taken us where he wants to
yeah I need I need a vehicle I make
better money when I have one we can
actually stay inside the vehicle you
know so it just that's our first goal or
step up to get up off the stream where
do you guys like to be in five years
you want an honest answer to that in
five years
uh
I want to be a counselor
uh not just a drug and alcohol counselor
with a spiritual counselor you know it's
probably gonna coincide with each other
uh
better coincide with getting off crack
cocaine too correct well I've done my
intern hours already
when I was in rehab
so I just I'm registered with car they
got that on record I just need my
classroom hours now
and cracked he said he could take her to
leave it I can you can take it or leave
it I really can at this point in my life
uh
I use more now than why are you taking
it then well because it's medicinal I
mean on the street you know it really is
I'm old you know I have to hustle hard
oh dude okay P3 you're 53 and I ride 30
miles a day and jump in and out of
dumpsters and it's hard
it's it's hard on the body and you
guys the black sheeps of your family
both of us are I am for sure
your whole family's Black Sheep if if
you ask if you ask my brothers yes but
if you ask my my parents uh no I was I
was a spoiled one I mean they love me
they give me everything I wanted
uh when my when my mom died uh I
inherited everything
and then my first wife took it from me
her cousin her cousin set me up
on a drug deal and
she got everything
so what would you guys have done
differently if you had another chance I
wouldn't do anything with her earlier
well yeah we spoke on that however you
know
I can't do anything differently
otherwise I wouldn't be where I am today
and I just have to thank God for all the
good and the bad and the other because
you know I my two youngest kids they
don't talk to me
they don't talk to me at all my oldest
one bless her heart she's on her way
here come hell or high water because
that's my I see my little sister she's
not my daughter she's my little sister I
treated her like a friend and I should
but I can't change yesterday you know
her drug started her life
yes and she's trying to leave it on the
way across the country because she knows
I won't I I meant to the fentanyl
capital of the country well see we don't
have we haven't had anything no Capital
here in San Francisco
Phoenix is for five hours I think the
whole country is Phoenix was got the
same problem Phoenix was freaky yeah it
was bad there it's worse I've ever seen
yeah it's just when you're here you feel
like it's the capital but you go to San
Francisco oh no that's the capital right
right it's a matter of perception yeah
it really it is it's just everywhere
look both my parents killed themselves
and it was about a year and a few months
apart well my dad was a cutter I didn't
even know what that was my daughter's a
cutter now I know okay so um my mom she
shot herself as soon as she saw my dad
but I told her I was going to drag her
Catholic ass through the mud for taking
my kid and she she deceived me by taking
permanent custody of her when it was
supposed to be six months temporary
I was in a Bible thumping church and
I'll tell you what I was clean I was
ready to take my kid and I threatened
her and I said oh drag your ass through
the mud through the streets of Bernie
and I would tell everybody what the [__]
you really are you know when she shot
herself the next day so for 20 years I
blame myself but I just got that off of
my back and off my chest because this
guy made me make it through every
holiday without
diving into the [__] drugs and and
sorrow you know what I mean when I made
it through one year I knew I could make
it through two but not without him
because
ah he's my strength he's my my post that
I lean on you know and uh my father he
did it I didn't even know that man I met
him and he's uh he had told me his whole
my whole life that he was going to bring
me to Michigan it never [__] happened
so I called him Tom not dad he was not a
dad to me my dad was the one that died
and so uh yeah after he left and went
back he told me while he was here he
said you know the best time to see
Michigan is in June and I was like like
I'm ever going to be there in June haha
he shot himself in June
so I was there for a whole month and I
enjoyed learning and meeting my siblings
and stuff and it's not a situation
that'll make or break you it's how you
handle the situation because my sister
we both have the same thing both of our
parents taught themselves right
the difference is I went to baseball and
dance I had a national champion dancer
and the number two pitcher in the state
of Texas when he was 13 because my
husband kept me focused you know we
didn't lose the kids
um my sister she lost all six of her
[__] kids she went to prison three
times she just died last year
the only women in my family are dead by
their 46-47 I'm 52 because there's a big
plan set up for me I don't even know
what we've both been functioning addicts
quite often you know a lot you know what
would you consider yourself both
functional absolutely yeah we have a lot
of willpower and a lot of you know drive
it's just oh a crack is a drug where you
can almost be functional if you can if
you if it's a mind over matter if you
can keep from just becoming if you can
keep from selling your grandma for it
well yeah it because it's it's yeah you
stay pretty sharp on it I've seen crack
addicts who are pretty together yeah
like I said I started when I was 14 and
I've I've had a good life quite a few
times it's just you know other other
circumstances happen maybe as a result
of drug use so you know I'm not gonna
put that out of the picture
it does cause problems in my life
sometimes and I've learned from it so I
mean but am I going to do it forever no
you know I can't see myself doing it
forever I'm getting old you know I made
them old I mean it's not funny it's not
really fun anymore it's not feasible to
do it I just do it like I said medically
actually you know it's kind of like uh
you spend a day
depends maybe
20 40 bucks that's it you know I mean I
don't
just Chase it back to back you know I
like the wheels it's not my purpose you
know that's not my goal you know I'm not
just people chasing to get a hit
you know
trying to get money together I'd rather
keep my money than spend it on that
right what are your what's your biggest
fear now
biggest fear
I fear nothing
um
I'm really I don't have any fears we try
not to worry because that makes you yeah
I don't focus on there's a pretty I'm
pretty
positive on life you know I mean I
I don't see anything because I don't
deserve anything bad to happen to me you
know I have that belief you know that
you get what you put out there you know
and we're not out there being harmful
we're out there sharing we deserve
anything bad so I don't think it'll come
my way you know I think I'm divinely
protected so to speak you know
I believe that I believe is it easier
because you guys are a couple yes
oh yeah I'm one of the only ones out
here that doesn't do tricks I didn't
know that when I came here he he told me
he's like
he was protecting me hardcore I had no
idea that every single one of them would
turn a trick that they would suck a dick
or something else for for drugs or money
well I have integrity and people don't
even know what that word is here
I have integrity I I this this this
ain't nobody getting in this because
this is mine
you know what I mean the only way
they're going to get there is if they
fight their way in and you better
believe they're going to fight because
I'm a rodeo country girl and I will [__]
some [__] up
I will ask him I have [__] him up and
I love him
true true story and we went three blocks
out out here one night I mean just rodeo
and and it's raining and it's misting or
whatever and we're down the middle of a
dark Street and I looked at him and I
said you better turn around and kiss me
tell them there is oh those cops on
every corner by the end I was like
they're behind me aren't they she's like
yes
he said yes because see I I've got
assault on peace officers in Bernie they
never stuck but uh five of them rodeoed
with me three of them quit because they
were pressing charges and the other two
just disappeared I don't know how it
happened but they went to go cut my
cross off my neck and I went stupid I
went just [__] redneck Rodeo
[__] and by the time they got me in
I spent 40 days and 40 nights in a
solitary cell in Kendall County while I
did need a freaking I didn't eat nothing
the whole time all I did was drink water
you know why because there was a purpose
there was I had to I had to get some
clarity and I did and I got out of there
and it took me two and a half years
three years for them to drop those
charges
but when I waited on the D.A and I
treated her like a human being not like
a person that was going to throw me
under the jail
they left me a huge tip and like the
next time I went to court it was all
gone every bit of it
every bit of it was gone
without me having to snitch on anybody
or anything every bit it was gone
because my boss told me get out there
and do your job
I did my job I almost threw up a couple
times at their table but it was their
anniversary and I had to serve them well
because that's what I was there for to
serve them so other than than pot you're
smoking what
me right now
nothing nothing just just pot pot so uh
well I try to get off the cigarettes and
so I'm vaping a little bit but
everything I'm using Crystal or anything
like that no I don't I don't mess around
that's the Devil's Dust We definitely
don't don't do crystalline I mean we
have but not anymore because I did it
for 30 years I don't want that [__] I
don't like it at all and I've noticed
it's got extras in it too I don't know
what they're putting in they said some
some mental [__] [__] or whatever
it's really folks with your psychics
yeah it makes your brain does stupid
makes you insane and you're partaking
Billy's crack oh yeah I smoke a little
crack oh you do oh sure I have a I'm not
supposed to be able to walk okay because
I have scoliosis both ways I'm supposed
to be in a wheelchair they're not my God
you know what I mean so I keep on going
but
it's like we don't really smoke and get
stupid like tweaking on the ground and
stuck on high you know it's
medicinal I might just do a little bump
and just keep pushing you know
it's just more for energy you know and
painkilling you think you'll stay out
here for a while uh you think you can
stay in Los Angeles for a while until
God moves us yeah you know and because
there's resources here you know and I
know people are here and and I
I'm waiting for the next right thing in
my past you know if I see I'm not like
I take advantage of my opportunities you
know that are presented to me there's
more opportunities here you know so if I
see a workable thing to get me to a
better quality of life so to speak or or
you know better situations yeah I'm all
for it you know I have to just be quiet
and follow him
so that's I'm just looking for the next
step up you know the next
workable thing
we do three things we stay prayed up
we do the next right thing
and then everything else will follow man
when God tells us to move we're up and
we're gone and he tells him first and he
tells me get that
it's it's kind of uncanny sometimes
because when I'm out there salvaging and
recycling I'll just be riding and then
all of a sudden I'll have a feeling
so to speak and I'll tell hey we gotta
go check this dumpster and sure enough
it's usually right there what we need we
got we made 2 800 in three days a few
years ago when we started saying 280
yeah I thought it was gonna be 280 bucks
I told I need 280 sometime this week and
uh ended up the last day uh of course
times 10. you need 280 bucks a day no so
that's what I need three days you know
to make it was going to be my phone bill
a couple other things and uh it ended up
being 2 800 by the third day when he
came back I thought he robbed somebody
and I was mad as hell
he came back from selling the gold teeth
I had 150 for a rug I sold and when I
woke up and I said how much did you get
and he dropped this wad on the bed my
heart hit the floor and I said who did
you Rob because we don't do shady [__]
at all I'm I'm All About Karma I'm not
having it come back on me right tell
them the rest
I just looked in the dumpster that I go
to quite often on my way back and uh
it was right on top in a plastic bag
there was nothing in it but a T-shirt
and I said I can use a t-shirt so I was
feeling it and there was something
inside of it I opened up the T-shirt
2800 bucks I mean 2100 bucks just the
rubber band right he didn't know how
much it was he shoved it in his pocket
got on his bike and rode away like he
stole it because I didn't know if
somebody threw that out there and was
going to come looking for it or if they
threw it out there to come out there and
get it later you never know I heard him
sliding two to the tent and I sat up
doing like this excited because we're
gonna maybe get a room and and you know
get off the street for a day
wow that was cool do you think you'd be
homeless for the rest of your life heck
no no no no we're not almost we're just
houseless I mean you think it'll be
houseless for the rest of your life no
what'll change that
um
well I've
I'm a pretty good Carpenter and uh I
really want to get a piece of property
and just build my own home you know live
off the grid like I'd like to I'm Mother
Earth I want to do everything from what
is here
you know I've got so many ideas that's
really what I'd like to do what would
you guys say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
foreign
don't have to fix everybody
you know even though I'd like to you
know I don't have to make everybody see
my point of view you know
all I can do is just share share my
reality with them and they can take it
or leave it you know I don't have to
hate people or dislike them because of
their point of view you know and we can
both be right
you know
sorry that was just really tough
I came across the desert saying if this
man didn't change and nothing was going
to change with us and he
I used to be real [__] to other
people you know I'm socially incorrect
you know I don't believe in the
government at all you know I don't I
don't trust any of that
because it's designed to fail
and I believe in humanity I believe
everybody's got subject to change to
change and have good in them well I
found out here in Los Angeles that I was
really wrong
there's there's evil out there that's
that's never going to be able to change
because it's not even human
and uh I figured this out sitting in in
between three churches
for many many hours I sat there
crocheting rugs they call me the rug
lady
and uh
I couldn't listen to a man that was
talking [__] to people all the time and
it's just not the way I treat people I
treat people the way I want to be
treated and when he would get foul with
them and [__] I would be like Ah that's
because I knew that they had you know
preconceived expectations and and
reasons why they were being nice to you
you know what I mean so I figured in the
recording and he's like you know I
didn't see all that you know what I mean
I yeah they
weren't nice what's nice about it
I could read between the lines yeah he's
been out here so much longer than I I
would I sheltered my kids I was
sheltered I was caught up in my life for
19 years with my husband you know and
then when Alan died
man he was my
he was my knight in shining armor and
then
my Jody my king my everything
I call him Jody because that's a family
name nobody calls him that anymore yeah
my mom used to go there
call him Jody you had to know me before
I was a teenager you know that
so most people if and I try not to say
that name out here because if somebody
calls him that I'm gonna put him up
against a wall by the throat you don't
call him that you don't know him like
that
that's my guy that's my name don't do
that even his best friend a quad polar
that's a new one quad polar
but yeah the we've had some wild
adventures across this country it's just
incredible
all right Billy and Valerie thank you so
much for sharing your stories thank you
for getting it maybe my kids will see it
realize I'm not that bad
you're not
wish you all the luck in the world yeah
luck is the result of hard work right we
stay blessed